We're waiting every night to finally roam and invite Newcomers to play with us For many years we've been all alone We're forced to be still and play The same songs we've known since that day Impostor took our life away Now we're stuck here to decay Please let us get in,
don't lock us away We're not like what you think We're poor little souls Who have lost all control And we're forced to take that role We've been all alone Stuck in our little zones Since 1987 Join us, be our friend Or just be stuck in the bed After all we only got Five nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay?
Five nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
Five nights at Freddy's Oh We're
really quite surprised We get to see you another night You should have looked for another job You should have said to this place goodbye It's like there's so much more Maybe you've been in this place before We remember a face like yours You seem acquainted with the stores Please let us get in,
don't lock us away We're not like what you're thinking We're poor little souls Who have lost all control And we're forced to take that role We've been all alone Stuck in our little zones Since 1987 Join us, be our friend Or just be stuck in the bed After all we only got Five nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay?
Five nights at Freddy's Is this where you wanna be?
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it Why do you wanna stay?
Five nights at Freddy's Oh